welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with
another incident of a minority being
targeted while performing everyday
activities a South Carolina woman is
facing assault and battery charges after
being accused of hitting a black
teenager at a community pool a camera
caught Stephanie Sebby strimm poll last
month as she appeared to verbally and
physically assault fifteen-year-old
darshan raka more simmons also known as
DJ we spoke exclusively with DJ and his
parents who believe he was targeted
because of his skin color
she called me anywhere as he called me
upon 15 year old DJ says he was invited
to the pool by a friend when Stephanie
said isse Trimble approached him 9-1-1
ok he says she physically and verbally
assaulted him and forced him to leave
this lady walked up to us and of late
you'll have to leave and you said you
say yes ma'am and I started walking now
she just started hitting me what were
you thinking when this woman is
assaulting you it was shocking the next
day
DJ showed the video to his parents who
believed the attack was racially
motivated as a mother when you saw that
what was your reaction it hurts you know
I could never imagine putting my hands
on somebody else's child all of those
adults there there was nobody to step up
and stop this lady say hey why are you
hitting this young man
Sebby strimm pole was arrested and
charged with third-degree assault and
battery
she was also fired from her job who took
the camera out and started recording
this I did why because I I knew it could
end up in a like the other side I
flipped around you knew that she would
possibly be believed over you yes
this incident is drawing comparison to
other recent confrontations captured on
video illegally
water without a permit including this
video where a woman calls the police on
a black eight-year-old girl selling
water on the sidewalk chocolate roses
are not allowed here in California this
woman called the cops on a black family
barbecuing in the park and in a Chicago
Park a man who rests as a woman for
wearing a shirt with a Puerto Rican flag
on it the woman asks an officer standing
a few yards away for help but the
officer appears to ignore the
confrontation he has since resigned from
the force here you've got a video you've
got audio you've got still shots of what
happened and it's it speaks for itself
DJ's attorney Margie Pizarro says he
handled the situation the right way we
saw him not retaliate when we saw him
walk away that was something that was
commendable DJ says he's entered
counseling to try and process the
alleged assault what did you learn I
learned from it I learned how to handle
it again if I have to deal with it what
did you learn about yourself I have a
lot of discipline
my self-control just think of this this
happened the day after he turns 15 the
day after he wins a championship for
basketball at the YMCA the day after his
great grandmother dies his grandmother
goes into the hospital he waited a day
to tell his parents this happened
because he was so concerned about their
mental state and on top of that this is
a kid who is on the basketball team the
football team is a distinguished
gentlemen's club member and is how does
that matter it doesn't he's just a kid
and and somebody should have helped him
and no matter how many times we see that
video it is just as disturbing every
time I don't know if this is naive to
say but when did we get so angry when
did everyone get so angry and that is
the question that is the question